AND START THIS HEALTH COMMITTEE
HEARING. YOU'LL NOTICE WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL HAVE.
OUR USUAL RULES OF THREE
MINUTES PER SIDE FOR THREE THE
TWO WITNESSES PER SIDE THREE
MINUTES EACH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES STATING ONLY THEIR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION RECORD
FOR THE POSITION ON THE MEASURE
WE HAVE THREE ITEMS BEFORE THAT
YOU. COLLEGE AS ARE ALL MIND
THEY'RE FAIRLY SIMPLE I WILL
HAVE I WILL TURN THIS OVER TO
MISTER BIGELOW UNTIL MR MAYES
ARRIVES. AND WILL GO AHEAD AND
GET STARTED
. MISTER WOULD YOU
HAVE THREE BILLS UP TODAY I
PRESUME YOU'LL GOING. ON FILE
ORDER AB ONE SEVEN FOUR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU NEED AT YOUR
HOUSE ON A MEMBERS AND AN SP
SEVENTY EIGHTS BUDGET BUT WE
CREATED THE INDIVIDUAL MARKET
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS WITH HOUSEHOLD
INCOMES AT OR BELOW 6100% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. THIS
BILL ALSO PROVIDED ADDITIONAL
SUBSIDIES. TO THOSE CURRENTLY
L. ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES AT OR BELOW THE 4100%
OF FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. AB
ONE SEVENTY FOUR WILL ENSURE WE
REVIEW THE ENROLLMENT FIGURES
COLLECTED BY COVER CALIFORNIA
AS A RESULT OF THESE NEW STATE
SUBSIDIES. THIS BILL ALSO
INCLUDES A TECHNICAL FIX TO IN
A RONI'S CODE SECTION IN THE
CORPORATION'S CODE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HAS
BEEN PALETTE FOR HELP ACCESS
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
CONSUMER ADVOCACY COALITION
HELP ACCESS IS PLEASED TO
SPONSOR AB ONE SEVENTY FOUR AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT IMPROVING
AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANCE FOR
THOSE IN COVERED CALIFORNIA WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR FOR PRIORITIZING THIS
ASSISTANCE IN THE BUDGET AB ONE
SEVENTY FOUR WILL ALLOW US TO
HAVE IMPORTANT DATA ON THE
SUCCESS OF THIS NEW PROGRAM FOR
THESE REASONS WE REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. VERY GOOD.
I DIDN'T KNOW HOW IT IN SUPPORT
GOOD MORNING AND JDS HERE ON
BEHALF OF SCA YOU CALIFORNIA
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IF NOT
IS THERE ANYONE WISHING TO
ADDRESS THIS IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING NO ONE RALLY TO THE CALL
BRING IT BACK TO MEMBERS ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR ON THIS BILL. MR WOULD
IT WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM WILL.
COLLECT A QUORUM AND THEN WILL
TAKE THAT BILL OUT WOULD LIKE
TO GO TO YOUR NEXT BILL I WOULD
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE IS A TWO
PART BILL THAT WOULD IMPROVE
HOW THE MEDI CAL. MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM FUNCTIONS. CUE THE MUSIC.
THAT WAS AMAZING WHEN I WAS OUT
OF I LOVE THAT SO WE'RE HEARING
THIS BILL BECAUSE OF AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE THAT WOULD
IMPROVE CARE COORDINATION AND
TREATMENT BY REQUIRING THE
EXCHANGE OF INFORMATION ABOUT
PEOPLE BEING TREATED BY
SEPARATE PLANS THE BILL WOULD
ALSO ESTABLISH A TIME FRAME FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO ISSUE A DECISION
WHEN THERE IS AN UNRESOLVED
DISPUTE BETWEEN THE COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLAN AND A MALE
AND MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE PLAN
I ASK FOR CONSERVE. CONCURRENCE
IN SENATE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU. I SEE YOU HAVE WITNESSES
OB WOULD YOU LIKE WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT WOULD YOU LIKE TO SHARE
WITH US LINDA AWAY WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY PROUD
COSPONSORS OF THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURES. WHICH ENSURES THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE ABLE TO TIMELY
ACCESS SIDE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WHEN THERE IS
DISAGREEMENT BETWEEN THE PLANS
ON. WHOSE RESPONSIBILITY IT IS
TO PROVIDE THAT SERVICE AS WELL
AS IMPROVED DATA SHARING ACROSS
THE HEALTH PLANS. ROGER I
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THE MORNING NATIONAL WITNESSES
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO BEHALF
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION PLEASED
WHEN SUPPORT. TERM MEMBERS
CADAMOSTO WITH THE LOCAL HEALTH
PLANS OF CALIFORNIA WE WENT
THINK THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US.
CONTINUALLY ON THIS BILL AND WE
THINK IT IT WILL CREATE GREAT
IMPROVEMENT IN THE SYSTEM SO WE
SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
JENNIFER HOLLYWOOD CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE AND THE SPONSORS WORKING
WITH US AND CAP ISN'T SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHERS
WISHING TO ADDRESSES AND
SUPPORT. IF NOT. ANYONE WISHING
TO ADDRESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SIGNAL IN RALLY TO THE CALL
MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
OF THE AUTHOR ON THIS BILL
WE'RE- DEALING WITH BILL AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE SING
NORMALLY TO THE CALL DOCTOR
WOULD WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
OUR WHICH I DIDN'T MOVE ONTO
NEXT OTHERS PROVIDE IF THAT'S
OKAY. THAT'S WORKS CUE THE
MUSIC. WE'LL DO OUR BEST OKAY
ERICA THANK YOU. MEMBERS THIS
THIS IS A BE SIXTEEN FORTY TWO
THIS YEAR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR AUDITOR RELEASED TO
CRITICAL AUDITS OF THE ON THE
MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE PROGRAM.
WE'RE HEARING THIS BILL BECAUSE
OF AMENDMENTS TAKING IN THE
TAKEN IN THE SENATE THAT WOULD
ENHANCE THE ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY. THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES BY
INCREASING THE PENALTIES FOR
THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS. THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ALSO REQUIRE DH CS
TO EVALUATE AND DETERMINE
WHETHER A PLANS ALTERNATIVE
ACCESS REQUESTS FOR A LONGER
TIME AND DISTANCE STANDARD IS
REASONABLE. TO EXPECT THE
BENEFICIARY TO TRAVEL IN
ADDITION THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE
PLANS TO ASSIST A PATIENT FIND
A CLOSER POSITION SPECIALIST.
WHEN THE PATIENT HAVE TO TRAVEL
A GREAT DISTANCE I A ASK FOR
CONCURRENCY IN OF THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
LYNN AWAY WITH WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT
OF THE THOUGHT THAT INCREASES
OVERSIGHT AND TRANSPARENCY OF
THANKS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT YES MA'AM PALLID WITH
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. DEBORAH BROWN WITH
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT. CUT
THE MUSTARD LOCAL HEALTH PLANS
CALIFORNIA WE'RE REMOVING
OPPOSITION AND AGAIN THANK
AUTHORED A STAFFER WORKING WITH
THE. CONNIE DELGADO BEHALF THE
COUNTY BE ABLE HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND STAFF WE ARE
REMOVING OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
AND JENNIFER I WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS WE TOO ARE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. THE
EFFORTS OF THE AUTHORS OFFER
THEM OFF. STAFF IN IN THE
SPONSOR THANK YOU. KELLY BROOKS
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
ROLE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WEEK TWO ARE HERE.
TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION AND
THINK THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
FOR ALL OF THE WORK THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO ADDRESSES AND
SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE. THOSE
THAT WISH TO ADDRESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO ONE RALLY
TO THE CALL MEMBERS DO ANY OF
YOU HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR BEFORE YOU ASKED THAT
QUESTION. PAGING ALL MEMBERS OF
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE WE ARE
STILL SHORT A QUORUM AND IF THE
STAFF IS LISTENING COULD YOU
PLEASE HELP YOUR MEMBER TO GET
HERE. SO THAT WE CAN NOT TAKE
THESE IMPORTANT MEASURES UP. NO
ONE HAS A QUESTION. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WHAT YOU'VE DONE AN
EXCELLENT JOB YOU'VE WRITTEN
MOVE THE OPPOSITION I'M VERY
PLEASED TO SAY. AT THAT MAKES
IT A LOT EASIER FOR EVERY
MEMBER HERE SO. UNTIL WE GET A
QUORUM THOUGH WILL HAVE YOUR
BILLS. RESTING FOR A MOMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OFFICIATE YOUR HELP NOT A
PROBLEM I'LL COME BACK AND- SET
UP THERE. YES
. YEAH RIGHT YEAH.
RIGHT
. BUT I YEAH. YEAH YEAH.
OKAY. I WILL. OKAY SO. YEAH.
YEAH. YEAH THIS. OKAY MA'AM
SECTOR WE HAVE A QUORUM PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WHAT HERE MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY BIGELOW. BONTA
BURKE CARILLO FLORA. LOW MOAN
MCCARTY NAZARIAN FROM OF
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO WALDRON. SO
WE HAVE THREE BILLS BEFORE SAID
LOVE TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION AB
ONE SEVENTY FOUR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTAKE YEAR CURRY SECOND BY
MISTER RAMOS THE MOTION IS
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WOOD HI WHAT I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE BONTA BONTA
AYE BURKE CARILLO CARILLO AYE
FLORA FLORA HI Là MON. MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON. NINE ZERO
THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES
SUBTILIS OUT WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD
ON PROBABLY THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHERS MEADOWS TO ADD ON. I AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE. A MOTION
BY MISTAKE YEAR CURRY A SECOND
BY MISS CARILLO MOTIONS
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS
MEN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHEN I WHEN I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE BONTA BONTA
AYE BURKE. CARILLO CARILLO AYE
FLORA FLOOR I LIVE ALONE
MCCARTY. NAZARIAN NAZARIAN I
RAMOS ROTH AYE RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
NINE ZERO THAT'S NINE ZERO THAT
BILL IS ALSO OUT AND WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD
ON. AND FINALLY AB SIXTEEN
FORTY TWO. MOTION BY MISTER
AGUILAR CURRY A SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO THE MOTION IS TO
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WOULD I WOULD I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE BONTA
BONTA AYE BURKE AREA CARILLO
AYE FLORA FLOOR I'LL AMONG.
MCCARTY. NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE
RAMOS RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
NINE ZERO THE BILL HAS NINE
VOTES HAVE BILLS THAT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER
STAT ON THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEMBERS FOR COMING IN AND THANK
YOU TO OUR OUR WITNESSES AND
SUPPORTERS. YEAH ACTUALLY
ACTUALLY FOR. YEAH NUMBER. YEAH.
YEAH AND- YEAH. I'M SERGEI WILL
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON AB ONE SEVENTY FOUR.
MAYES WORK AMOUNT MCCARTY
RODRIGUEZ. YEAH RODRIGUEZ AYE
WALDRON. YOU CAN THAT'S NOW TEN
ZERO OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON A. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE. MAYES BURKE LOW
MOAN MCCARTY RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE WALDRON. TEST TEN
ZERO AND FINALLY PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON A. B. SIXTEEN FORTY
TWO MAYES BURKE LOW MOAN
MCCARTY RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
WALDRON. THAT'S TEN ZERO THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISS RODRIGUEZ
.
SORRY. ESTIMATES GOOD MORNING
MORNING A MAN SECRETARY PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON AB ONE SEVENTY FOUR.
MAYES MAYES I. BURKE LOAN
MCCARTY WALDRON. ELEVEN BEST
ELEVEN ZERO PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE MAYES HI
MAYES I. BURKE LIMóN MCCARTY
WALDRON. ELEVEN ESTO LEVIN ZERO
AND FINALLY OF PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON
A P. SIXTEEN FORTY TWO. MAYES
AYE MAYES AYE. BURKE LIMóN
MCCARTY WALDRON. ELEVEN ELEVEN
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
MESS. WE WILL WAIT FIVE MINUTES
HERE AND THEN WE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE ON EVERYTHING
. YEAH. YEAH
TALK. OKAY
. NO THAT'S FINE
THANK YOU MEN SECTOR PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FOR A BE A LEAD OF ONE
SEVENTY FOUR EXCUSE ME. BURKE
BURKE HI. LIMóN MCCARTY
WALDRON. THAT'S TWELVE ZERO
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON A. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE. BURKE BURKE I.
THE MOAN MCCARTY WALDRON. WELL
ZERO AND FINALLY PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON A. B. SIXTEEN FORTY
TWO BURKE BURKE I. LIMóN
MCCARTY WALDRON THAT'S TWELVE
ZERO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SORRY FOR AN EIGHT THIRTY
MEETING. LIKE THE FORTY FIVE.
YEARS YOUR STAFF LET US KNOW.
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
CLOSE THE ROLE ON THIS ON ON
THESE BILLS AND CONCLUDE THIS
MEETING OF THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. OR OKAY